Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, look who I met randomly in Apex.
That's our story, right?
Tenjin, that's...
Is he something, Tenjin?
Come on!
Who is this man?
He's fucking old, that's who.
Nice to meet you.
My name is Tenjin.
Fuck off!
I met Doki randomly in a lobby.
Hey Tengen, hey Tengen's chat.
Fuck off.
Yeah, yeah, we met randomly in a pubs match in Apex.
And I was like, whoa, dude, you should be a streamer.
And so I did.
Yeah!
I did.
I started this man's career.
Yeah.
yeah hell yeah yeah oh my god i've been trying to poop it
doesn't oh yeah yeah he's been having like digestive issues
well to be fair there's been a lot of issues but he's been
he's been issues you've been what do you mean you were
you're always sick what the do you mean you're always what
do you mean what do you know about me we just met oh i mean
like today you were telling Okay, that's a lie because you
called me out on stream.
Like that's a That's a fucking lie You literally called me
out on stream.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
A few days ago.
I was lurking and he called me out Yeah, yeah, what's your
excuse?
No, it didn't happen.
That didn't happen.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that fucking thing You do know people
clipped us, you know Whoa, I got clipped No way You got
fucking clip I'm nobody I I was fucking lurking Bro I oh by
the way By the way Tengen I told them You remember that the
Remember that Tarkov story You told me The one where you
like The one where you spent money on Tarkov After the whole
scam thing Because it was 80% off It was 50% off It was 50%
yeah Yeah they Like I told that story I told that story but
didn't mention like who it was it was this man but it was 50
off they literally just got out of a scam yo i'm blind
you're blind was it worth it was it was it was not it was
not if it was 80 then it would have been worth it but like
you know it definitely would be yeah 50 percent Anyway,
guys, guys, someone quick refund him that money right now.
Someone refund him that money.
I'm about to get reimbursed.
Reimbursed time to ask Steam for a refund real quick.
I can't aim.
Oh, nah, this thing is not tough.
Okay, I'm good.
All right.
I'm dead.
Are you dead already?
We literally just, oh my god, we literally just started to
wait.
Do we have a new castle?
Wait, there's a new castle here.
everyone here there's no there's literally a new castle
thing here that means there's a yeah is there a team here no
the enemy has a oh oh okay okay okay that's fine that's fine
whoa are we getting rena we're getting no we're not i
knocked one our teammates dead my left oh he's so low yeah
he's dead he's dead he's dead Yay!
Yee-pee!
Nice, our teammates dog shit.
Alright, so where have you been playing?
Where have you been- Oh, what the fuck?
How is he dead again?
Got you?
I got it.
Are you good?
Oh, you are not good.
You are not good.
I am not.
How?
Oh my god, he's- Holy shit!
I'm fucking- Bro, okay, I'm definitely lagging.
Yeah, well, you insisted playing here.
Yeah, yeah, okay, look.
Okay, look, it'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
I just...
I hit, like, seven bullets and none of them registered.
I just need you to know that.
Oh, shit.
Also, chat, how's the volume for Tengen now?
How is that?
Is that okay?
How's my volume on Tengen stream, too?
You'll be fine.
I mean, I put you on compressor.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, so what have you been playing recently, Dungeon?
I know you've been playing that finals game for just a
tournament.
Uh-huh, even though it's just for tournament.
Yeah.
What did I play?
Yeah, what have you been playing?
Look, we've been having a rut, okay, guys?
We have like...
That's a good question.
We have, like, zero FPS games to play these days.
It is a hard time for FPS games.
Yeah, it's a hard time for us.
I like how someone said Tengen, life alert fund, but then
super chat it to me.
Thank you, man.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure Tengen gets it.
Oh, wait.
Have you tried X-Fion yet?
Um...
My friend's been trying to convince me to play, actually.
The good part is that there's no skill-based matchmaking.
Yeah, that's what I heard.
heard and it's like overwatching call of duty at the same
time don't like the pace how do you not like the pacing you
never played it yet i played the close beta like oh yeah you
got in beta oh okay yeah you think it's better than i got in
twice i felt i don't know is it is it just me like that i
haven't been touching that game in a while because like it
feels slower for somebody or am just thinking oh no i
haven't tried it yet because when the beta oh right they're
literally on the tree bro i'm blind they're literally right
in front of us tendon what the that's why you're old i'm not
old why do you have white hair you the stress from me we met
like today what do you
It took you two hours to have white hair.
Oh my gosh.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's their whole team.
You can 1v3 that.
You're tension.
What does that mean?
That's what I mean.
You'll be fine, right?
Yeah, see?
Wait, where's his teammate?
Nice.
Nice, man.
That is a long finish.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
bro took everything i killed yeah bro like what the wrong
with him bro i know right this is this is why he took
everything this is why chat this is why this is why you have
white hair i can't believe that man would do that i haven't
even i haven't even It was close.
We almost leaked it.
You know, if he had all his stuff, he would have.
Gorillas.
Yeah, he would have gorilla debut.
And I was like, do it.
He was like, shit out.
And I was a bad influence.
I was like, you should.
Man.
A bad idea is still an idea.
I mean, it would have been pretty cool.
It would have been funny.
I would have thought it would have been funny.
Because you're like...
It would be just be like like first stream That's not like
the fucking finals I like how your first stream Like back
was the finals Like just some random tournament That was
like Hi I'm back I'm playing tournament now Yeah yeah you're
like I'm back By the way this is a tournament stream You
wanna know what happened Thing is a friend of mine Got like
invited to a tournament And he was so like hey You should
invite two more guys You're in something like that it was it
was like five minutes from the announcement yeah oh my god
without even asked two of us me including the other teammate
was registered without being asked oh you would they just
registered yeah knowing that we'd say yes they're just like
whatever you know whatever 10 just gonna say yes anyway yeah
crazy this guy yeah so that means i can oh yeah but yeah i
told them i told them like you were like one of the first
subs for that Nokia tournament and then my chat, my chat
said you got region locked in the IRL.
He actually got region locked IRL.
Do not, do not send stuff from international shipping to
Indonesia.
They're like, yeah, they're like, yeah, we don't know if
he's gonna get in in time because of customs.
Oh, there's people in front of us.
Hey, someone's in front of us.
Yeah, wait, there's someone below.
What the fuck?
Someone's in front of you.
Yeah, what is he doing here?
dude oh my god where did this guy come from i thought it was
like our decoy just now for some reason i was like that had
to be a decoy that was a chat i didn't see if you guys think
if if tension sound is okay wait where are you shooting oh
teammates over there yep they went over there does this hit
no Doesn't hit!
Okay.
I'm just gonna get closer.
It's okay, they can't drop down now.
It's okay?
Alright.
Alright, I'll wait.
Okay, I'm heading up.
They ran?
Wait, no, they didn't.
On me?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I got shot from behind.
It's okay, I'm just gonna walk back.
Wait, I'm so safe.
I'm so safe.
Trust, trust, trust, trust.
Uh-huh.
Trust, trust, trust, trust, trust, trust.
Yeah, see, I told you.
Nice.
Always believe in me.
Oh.
Okay, I'm Phoenix Kid.
Let me know if they're pushing up.
I'm Phoenix Kidding.
Let me know.
Okay, that is...
Oh, okay.
We're dead.
No, we're not.
Shoot!
Why are you shooting the thing?
No, no, no, no, no.
I fear.
Oh my god!
Shoot the thing!
Oh god.
Oh!
No!
Oh shit!
What's wrong with my E?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Mirage, please res me.
Mirage!
No!
It's literally Mirage!
Okay, our Mirage fucking sucks.
I hate him.
I hate our Mirage.
Our Mirage is...
What do I do?
There's a different way.
Terrible.
Wait, there's different teams?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Why did he not res?
Okay.
He's invisible.
This mirage is terrible.
This guy has 300 damage?
Bro, I'm lagging in my...
Damage.
Is he crafting us?
Bro is not crafting us here.
He is crafting us.
Bro is not crafting us here and reviving us.
here no why is he alting bro is he actually rising us here
wait bro are you invisible yeah but why did he why did he do
that oh we're so we're so fucked we're so fucked we're so
fucked oh no we're so dead i hope they shoot you first no
way oh no we're so fucked i love this they're gonna they're
flying oh no where are they flying we're already flying
tension i don't know oh oh on us they're on us aren't they
they're on us aren't they are they on us oh wait wait wait
wait we get our stuff we can get our stuff wait wait we can
get our stuff they flew to him they flew to him wait he's
dead let's get her stuff let's get her stuff all right all
right everything out so yep yeah it all yeah everything
worked out for us we'll we'll give it back to you man yeah
yeah yeah we'll um we'll we'll be back don't worry give it
to the next person yeah yeah yeah double it and give it to
the next person don't worry we'll be there oh he turned
front of us they're in front of us they're in front of us
they're in front of us they're in front of us they literally
flew to us they literally flew to us what what did you do
one's cracked one's cracked fully low like that's two shots
directed you're good you're good you're no i'm not i don't
feel good i don't feel good i don't feel good i don't think
we we did it yeah we could just queue up yeah yeah we could
queue again yeah just thank you apex yeah thank you so we
don't have to bro they actually blocking what the what's
wrong with them freaks Greeks.
Okay, to be fair, we had a terrible third.
Like, to be fair, our third was... Maybe we needed a fourth.
Yeah, maybe we need a fourth player to make up for this
Mirage.
We do.
Oh, yeah.
So, wait, so X to 5, and you just think it's, like, way too
slow?
Um...
I guess, but, I mean, I'll give it a shot, right?
Yeah.
I'm not down.
I was planning to download it to like bro let's fucking play
it let's freaking play it let's do it next week because like
this weekend yeah fucking let's do it let's do it next week
yeah we'll play on your servers because your internet's dog
no like literally last week like some cable on the ocean was
like broke down into like something i guess yeah so we got
like redirected to another whole server so we could not
connect to singapore so it just there's a whole lot of
latency for a couple of while wait was that for like
indonesia only uh i guess it happened for like five four
days oh my god how do you how do you live like that i can't
i don't know it's been decades i've got this i'm just like
thinking like we we had worse we had we had wait so a sharp
bit the cable probably what the fuck well we never knew what
really happened i just said like i just suddenly got emailed
like oh something's wrong under the water so we're sorry
here's a compensation oh my god no the server oh wait oh
it's okay guys i thought i thought that was my internet that
would so funny if that was my internet i was like oh no the
shark fit another cable like there's no way that was like
the timing of that too i was like there's no way a shark
literally fit another cable nice okay oh no that's not the
gun i wanted oh what the oh i might need help oh wait no
he's low he's flesh wait man what the fuck am I oh what
that's calm down that's sorry I was that's why I was
watching the horizon the horizon was pretty embarrassing you
were yelling at me and you're spectating at the raw person
look no no no I was still knocked okay I still look Look, I
didn't realize you were not the horizon.
But you're playing...
Wait, what's her name again?
I already forgot her name.
I care.
Alter?
What do you think about Alter?
I'm not even sure.
It's fun.
I think...
Like, I can make portals randomly and then people would just
get thrown off.
I feel like Alter...
I made a portal out of nowhere and they just go through it.
I feel like Alter, you need to have a good team to play with
her.
Because she's so...
Oh, she's...
Hey, who the fuck is this?
This guy's bad connection.
wait what the fuck wait hey who the fuck is this who is that
guy whoa and got him he did i need a heal oh i'm okay can i
swap i can swap is there a swap one's knocked one left
behind that stone oh there he is you got this right flesh
bro i swear to fucking i'm okay i have a gold rest shield
yeah that's why i literally just got it you don't even know
yeah oh i know don't worry about it i'm your teammate i know
sure sure there's a phoenix hit here oh you already have one
okay i'm using one right now yay all right what's that dude
with the freaking whatever hop up thing all right what's
your what are you planning on streaming now that you're
back.
I got to debut first, at least.
You can be a PNG.
Forever?
No, thanks.
I want to move.
Yeah, but you can be a PNG until you debut because you don't
know when you're debuting yet.
Maybe tomorrow.
Wait, actually?
Wait, what?
So, like, legit, it's just a stinger.
It's just a stinger.
Yeah, I am.
But you don't know when that's going to be.
you know like i begged like you can just debut without the
stinger and then you just like it just shows up one day yeah
because the intro and the outro is done so yeah it's just
the singer yeah so yeah i know what it looks like chat i
know what it looks like no you don't yes i do
No, I shouldn't make you bet like you don't deserve that
What if I changed my hair color?
You had changed the hair color just to spite me just to fuck
with me.
Yeah, I'm against you That's so fucked up man.
That's so fucked up.
I am again.
Yeah hell Yeah, he's he's like an old And oh, yeah, you're I
shouldn't reveal your lore yet Because it's a secret it's
crazy.
Yes, you did you fucking told me the lore Oh, you didn't?
Yes, you did?
Nuh-uh.
I could say it right now and...
I could say it right now.
Nuh-uh.
What?
Are you gonna bait me?
Are you...
What are you talking about?
Yeah, bro.
Don't fucking...
Oh, don't bait me because now I really want to say it.
Hell.
Anyway, he's gonna be like...
Like, he's, I don't know if you guys know, but he's really
old.
And, um...
I mean, I'm dead.
He's, like, an old grandpa.
Um, and, like, in his lore, he has, like, white hair.
It's always about the white hair.
It's the only thing I can say that won't actually leak
anything.
That's, that's honestly true.
Oh, my God.
That's all you guys know.
need to know people didn't know that i'm an old guy that's
the thing man yeah so old they wasn't supposed to know
you're not supposed to know you're old then change your hair
color i'm 12.
oh seconds away from dying oh oh my god to be fair when are
you like not dying though to be honestly every good question
i feel like after maybe you won't even get a stream tomorrow
because you're gonna fucking get like you're hoping me to
die no i'm just talking about the odds the odds of that
happening you know the odds of me dying because of natural
causes is way smaller than getting into an accident okay i'm
just saying putting it out there just don't go outside yeah
just like imagine There's like a random shark just jumping
at me.
Just don't go outside, Tengen.
Then you'll be fine.
But I like touching the grass.
No, you don't.
What do you mean?
You assume I just stay at home?
If you had a choice, you would 100% just stay at home.
What do you mean?
Yeah, I was going to say it.
I was like, there's no fucking way you hate going out.
Like, what?
Honestly, you're right.
I mean, you're so right.
that bro like okay i was gonna say we even though i know you
for like a couple of days just a couple of days i know that
you do not like to go outside from those experiences from a
couple of days guys just you know yeah she's saying i'm a
virgin chat yeah that too i mean that's crazy he's a he's a
she called me a fucking virgin that's crazy no no it's
called a You're like a level 100 wizard right now.
You don't want to break that streak.
She's calling me old now.
I was calling you old since the stream started.
My title is literally grandpa.
It's literally carrying this old grandpa.
Where are we going?
We're just rotating.
I see nothing.
I don't want to be outside of Zor.
That's stupid.
That's true.
Oh, shit.
wrong is she is she damn even the chats are against me you
know
i did my job influencer yeah i'm an influencer guys double
it and give it to the next one
wait were you watching that part in rust is that why the
part where i was like hello i'm an influencer i think i was
yeah i was like why were you outside you were smoking
outside just watching me fuck around in her ass okay again i
miscalculated the stream time and my sleep time yeah i was
like ah it's time to stream i woke up it's 2 a.m but what am
i gonna do what the fuck this guy just yeah yeah he had
white armor by the way there's another team up at the hill i
was not like being outside the zone yeah but like we can
gatekeep them um or i could put a nexus oh true true true
you're so smart i forgot about that oh no they're still
there but i saw them chilling up there yeah my mr beast arc
just double it and give it to the next one oh the ring is
even like you sure about this I mean, it's round two.
I think there are two that are left.
Oh, they're not!
They're not!
They're left!
They were ab- You big liar.
Big liar.
Oh my god!
I'm not a liar!
I just didn't know!
You big lie, man.
Oh my god.
I mean, you killed all of them.
I'm fucking going to the Nexus.
I wiped the whole two of them.
Yeah, I'm going to the Nexus.
Bye.
Yeah, I gotta loot all this stuff first, though.
I think there's another team near us.
Yeah, there should be, at least.
All right, I'm going back.
This shit hurts, yo.
Yeah, it's round two, though.
It's not that bad.
I don't see another team, though, near us.
Yay.
Oh, ow, ow, ow.
I don't have a med kit!
I'm fucked.
You don't have syringes?
I have syringes, but not med kit.
Ah!
I didn't have a red med kit also.
Oh, you almost timed that wrong.
Yeah.
You almost...
I predicted it wrong.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, look.
There should be meds here.
Okay, I'm going to grab some syringes.
Oh, okay.
I found three fucking bats instead.
If you want.
I need kits and syringes.
Yeah, I...
This is my last one.
I have one syringe here.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's do this.
I know there was a one behind us, but I'm lazy.
I'm too lazy to take that.
I'm too lazy to walk behind us.
I'm going to go to the other one.
crazy oh i'm gonna go to zone wait behind us up top you see
oh oh why am i being shot at behind us just don't let them
break our just don't let them break our armor then we'll
have uh significant advantage yeah because we just don't
have heals that's really it as long as they don't break our
armor we're fine are they shooting us from uh from that what
the is wrong with him what yeah i don't know what am i
looking at wait where's the other team then okay they're
behind a shield i ain't fighting that yeah i'm not fighting
that that's stupid they're behind a shield yeah i'm not
doing that i broke their shield we're shooting me without it
now because i broke wait someone died to ring wait what the
other team is dying to ring what the fuck yeah because
they're the ones to our left yeah but who's the ring people
i don't know what the fuck why are they dying what are we
ever gonna do we just wait this is they have to come to us
yeah see they're over here left side i told you look see oh
that is super low yeah i told you he just had to come to
Perfect made?
No?
Never mind.
Flash?
No, it's...
That's not reachable.
I'm just gonna push up a little.
Oh, one is up here, by the way.
Yep.
Wait, this is two different teams.
I just realized.
One is above us and the other ones start left.
Uh...
Oh shit, that's me.
Yeah.
Why are they...
So one is like up here.
There's so much stuff.
It's fine.
We'll be fine, right?
Are we?
I believe in us.
Oh, shit!
Okay, that guy was stupid.
Help me over here.
With this guy.
I can't climb.
There's some reason.
Alright, I'm gonna take his loot then.
Wait, what?
Who's this guy?
He's just, he's just cute.
All right.
Where did he come from?
Okay, I'm just gonna heal.
You're fine, right?
I'm fine.
You're fine?
Okay, I'm gonna take his, I'm gonna loot then.
Are you still fine?
Oh my god, he went down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, where's the last guy then?
Don't know.
We're alive?
I wouldn't even...
know i don't know where he is i swear i saw some guy here
where the fuck did he go okay what the fuck where did he go
oh oh wait oh he's behind wait that's the whole team that's
the whole team that's the whole team that's the whole team
oh i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay okay okay don't let them push
don't let them push i think it's kidding where did this team
come from oh i'm dead i'm dead dead I peeked me oh I'm okay
I'm not dead I'm not dead I'm not dead I'm not dead I'm not
dead I'm gonna go for the scat is one behind you behind you
I know I need to okay I got one I'm gonna flourish this guy
I'm gonna thirst him he's right here he's right here I'm
gonna thirst him though okay I'm getting over don't die I'm
here okay he's the gym too there's no way he wins this one
b2 yeah he's one nice see oh he said sorry yeah you better
be what do you say what do you say he said sorry oh my god
oh my god oh my god Wow My god he was stream sniping us
Tension Oh my god This guy This guy You're gonna stream snip
us You should have had more than 1k damage Not gonna
This is a little embarrassing You don't know if he's a
dragon He could be like Whatever the fuck Tensions chat is
What do you call your chat?
Bro.
I have yet to reveal that just yet.
Reveal?
Let's do it now.
No.
Why not?
It would be like an exclusive.
Hell no.
Anjing.
Is it anjing?
Wait, what's that mean?
Tenjin, I've never heard that before.
What is that really?
oh yeah i've never heard that it means it means a dog or a
oh yeah how do you say that fully
how do you say that fully then attention uh yeah
unjing isn't there more to that i'm pretty sure that was
really really there's no need to or not uh probably not chat
is that is that true yeah let me look at your chat you
should have more your chat would tell the truth your chat
would tell the truth all right no nah yeah my chat's a
gaslighter
nah wait do you call your chat on ding now times yeah oh my
god you call your chat dogs yeah sometimes maybe they like
it yeah they do i i'm sure they do i'm sure they do tangents
on jings
guys i can't get in trouble because it's tangents fault what
it's not my fault i'm just trying I'm just trying to learn.
Stay on me.
I'm just trying to learn.
My behavior is mostly because of my friends.
Me too.
So I blame my friends too.
Thank God we just met each other.
Yeah, thank God we just met, so we're not friends.
We...
We're just acquaintances, guys.
Wait.
Equations.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where we were just randos.
Yeah, we're just randos.
We just want to win some Apex games, you know?
We like Apex.
Yeah, we're just like, damn, you're so good at Apex.
Like, you want to, like, fucking do a collab so we can boost
our win rates.
Oh, I got the wrong person with that.
Whoops.
Hope you don't die.
Any over?
Wait, there's a guy right here in front of me.
Yeah, someone's on you.
Were you champions?
No.
What the fuck?
What is I?
Oh, my...
Oh my god, I couldn't even look.
I'm so fucked.
All right.
Whoa, yeah, that guy instantly killed me.
It was actually crazy.
I literally looked up and got...
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh my god, maybe he'll res me too.
Let's go, gamers.
I got scatting?
Oh, shit.
I'm safe, though.
I'm really safe.
I'm really safe, Tengen.
What?
Okay, you're dead.
I'm still very safe.
There's a whole different team.
I'm safe for res.
No lie.
Do you think he'll res me?
Oh, he got peace keep.
Okay, he's fucking dead.
Wait, wait, he won that.
Oh, he's dead.
There's two shotguns in that team.
Oh, he should have resed.
He should have resed.
We would have fucking helped him.
We would have, yes?
Yeah.
Wait, I have an idea.
You have zero.
damage okay i literally looked up and died can't that's not
fair welcome to my servers no nna we would have fucking died
so fast that's where all the ruler players live you know
that you played any servers not i guess you have i have not
what are you talking about true true true sorry i was
thinking about somebody else we i think we met in tokyo like
we met like the day before your final the finals tournament
that's why I was lurking in his chat if you guys want a
timeline of everything yeah yeah that's that's our timeline
that's that's the canon event uh right yeah yeah and we met
on like Tokyo servers right mm-hmm yeah yeah so it was on
Tokyo servers uh that we bumped into each other and then
like it was off stream like real dokey yeah oh my god yeah
and he's like a huge fan of me by the way so he's actually a
dragoon he's been like a uh like uh he's been a dragoon
member for like how many months now five months right why
don't you prove it in chat right now in my chat and type a
show your membership badge to show that it's real hey aren't
you a member was what happened we became friends oh i
thought we were acquaintances
we became friends oh yeah we just became friends like right
now so he i can't be a fan and a friend at the same time
yeah so why aren't you mending i need to pay my electricity
okay true all right don't worry you can never die now you
think my water bills are like
crazy that's crazy damn that's you got me there yeah he had
to cancel his he had to cancel his like membership to me
because he had to pay his shows yeah it's okay guys the
gases ain't so like guys that means guys guys that means
like guys you have to super chat to tension so that He can
member, he can afford to member to.
Guys, I need him to member to me.
So, so.
Why do you want me to member you?
I have your chat open.
Someone literally gave you a super chat.
Why you have my chat open?
That, that, that's so, what?
Hey, that's crazy.
Because you said you couldn't afford it.
You said you couldn't you couldn't afford it.
So now you should be able to afford it now right unless you
were lying to me Yeah, never lie.
All right remember me right now.
I'm I'm in Apex.
Do you expect me to remember?
Oh, don't worry at the end of the stream.
You're we're gonna watch you remember me, right?
What is that statement man doing tomato farm what?
Nah!
People are just staring me to do this now, huh?
Well, your pressure is okay sometimes.
Sometimes?
Oh, you're right all the time.
You're right.
Sometimes?
All the time.
There's like a huge fight going on in front of me, by the
way.
Don't worry, I'm lifelike.
If you go there and die, and then I raise you just like
Mercy.
die i have res what the is going what are you doing here
have a healer drone you deserve it i yeah you deserve this
oh in front of me in front of me in front of me okay okay
knocked one second buddy person is here right what is he
doing here got the second one
What?
Die, I have res, just like Overwatch.
What are you just like Overwatch?
I'm like, Mercy.
What's you fucking do?
I don't want...
I've never played Overwatch.
What are you talking about?
How do you know that?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Die, I have res, just like Marble Rivas.
And you know, you can't say you don't have it.
You don't, you know.
Okay, okay.
You can't lie.
The reason why you can't lie.
Because I gave him a fucking code for Marble Rivals.
Yeah, so I'm calling you out.
I gave this man a fucking code of Marble Rivals, so you
can't lie about it.
It's so cozy.
What?
You sold your soul to me now.
Bro!
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
This is your fault.
No, I learned that you want a code for Marble Rivals?
And you're like, yeah, I knew.
No, this is your fault.
Someone sent a red.
Oh, someone sent a red.
Oh, you know, you know what to do.
This is your fault.
How is that my fault?
I'm doing this.
What the fuck?
You are a scam.
I can't believe it.
This guy scammed me.
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
Hail.
I can't believe it.
Where's membership?
I ain't even even the beauty.
That's...
Man.
What?
Where are we going?
I don't know.
I'm fucking...
Your, north.
Your IGF.
I'm Lifeline." Okay, we're following the Bangalore.
Okay, you so nasty.
Why?
That's the guy's name!
What do you mean?
Why?
That's literally the guy's name.
Oh, that's the guy's name.
I'm streaming.
Anonymous mode.
Are you scared of dying?
Is this somebody?
No.
Get your shit off of streamer mode.
Get your shit off streamer mode.
What are you scared of?
What are you laughing about?
No, no, no, don't worry about it.
What are you doing?
I'm pulling up your stream right now.
Nothing, nothing, nothing.
What are you doing?
There's nothing, there's nothing.
There's nothing.
What are you doing?
Nothing.
Now I didn't do anything.
Don't worry about it.
What is he doing?
They don't worry about it.
Nothing.
I didn't do anything.
Oh, you did something.
You fucking did something.
I didn't do anything.
Why did you don't trust me?
We literally just met you already.
No, no, no.
You trust me.
I do trust you to the point where I cannot trust you.
Because I trust you to not trust.
That's how hard it is.
For real.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I have a package.
Oh, I see him!
Cracked one!
They're like all the way over to the other side.
What do we have here?
Someone's flying?
Wait, is there?
They're flying over there.
Oh, wait, they are.
That's the team I like cracked, I think.
Yeah, they are.
Wait, where?
I don't see them.
Really?
Oh, I see them!
I see them!
Do we have do I have ammo?
I need ammo.
What kind of ammo do you need?
Blue armor, red, I'm doing season three meta Wait, PK or
not?
Oh, you're doing PK wingman.
I fucking knew it Like the moment he's like season three.
I fucking knew this Bro has a dictionary even remembering
Bro season three is season three and four were my friend out
late like Friend years a fucking course I remember season
three fucking meta ingrained in my mind you were over here
and to my right as well there's like i don't know the same
team ship you should craft some you can craft some ammo i i
thought i cracked something already dude okay probably i
mean they're playing gibby and octane why are they playing
gibby i've never see gibby anymore i swear to god because
isn't it he's moved what do we move where do you do that
gibby not moving isn't that gibby just chilling behind the
rock oh it's because there's a new team yeah this gibby is
so oh my god this gibby is so um like a nexus i'm gonna yeah
get that nexus in
you go first wait you have a user portal you could literally
wait where can i can't does it even go through that no it
does not oh here i can do that over there oh okay yeah yeah
it's kind of like his teammates though why is he taking the
nexus what what did he fuck up did he use up the nexus why
did he use the nexus oh he's stupid he's special it's
singapore service okay damn in front of us literally have a
sniper so i'm counting on your right wait he is on your
right yeah he is dude who's on your right what the fuck i
thought you were supposed to help me he ran away why is he
scared because you're dope we should we should go for the
guy to our lefts that one yeah i don't know i don't see him
but yeah oh my god cracked like two of them he's so low You
got this, I believe in you.
Literally one...
Oh!
It's okay.
Watch this.
That's why I'm lifeline.
Yo, you even got like a field drone.
Someone's behind you, told you about it.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
Where are you?
Wait, where did you die?
You're in.
No.
I told you.
You're so fine.
Huh?
Oh my God.
you guys we have to go go oh i'm leaving by the way the
stones coming ow hey but i have a package i'm so healthy i
know there's like one more team somewhere here you have your
cue uh no i used it uh but i do have a knockdown shield
would i need that um we need a go-go i'm gonna take the
redeploy i have a thingy whatever the reply yeah yeah i'm
gonna take that then you guys can take yours i'll take this
in front of me let's go bang come on so funny if i die from
getting shot from this it'll be so funny it'll be so funny
where are we Are we straight?
I don't know.
Let's head to zone.
We're literally so far from zone.
Yep.
I'm gonna head to this actually and then fly over it.
Do another jump tower?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, we're fine.
We're so safe.
Like what are you gonna do?
Kill us?
Someone's resing.
Where?
Oh, okay.
Then we'll go here.
We'll land here.
That's good.
Yeah.
And then we'll shoot them and kill them.
Oh, I see them.
They're too far left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's literally right there.
Okay.
Yeah, there's nobody here.
There's nobody here.
I'm going to go up.
I think they just crafted a mobile res beacon, I'm pretty
sure.
You can craft a mobile res beacon.
I think you can, right?
There's a lot of dead bodies in there.
That must be where they died.
Oh, I see them.
Oh.
Full team, full team, full team, full team.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to chill.
I'm chilling.
Whoa!
Oh, back away!
I'm using my heal drone.
I just want to step on that place.
Come on.
Where the fuck are you doing?
It's so funny.
If someone steps in there.
They are not stepping.
You know damn well they're not stepping on it.
Oh, they will.
Eventually they will.
They're not stepping on it, Tension.
They're not stepping on it.
Eventually they will.
Trust me.
though yeah they're not in zone all right we're not in zone
yeah i was gonna say engine didn't step on it i thought you
said they were nobody's that blind don't worry about it i am
oh let me see i can climb up this nice okay oh what okay i
fucked up i fucked up they might rush now i fucked up i
thought they weren't gonna turn around i literally walked
them guys i really need a res
You have the mobile.
You have the mobile res.
You have the gold res, right?
Oh, they're here.
They're here.
I'm going to take you.
Okay, that Nexus is...
You'll be fine.
Okay.
Taking your Nexus.
I'm taking your Nexus.
You got me right.
No, no, no, no, no.
Bro, what the fuck is this Nexus?
You got me right.
Take the Nexus.
Take the fucking Nexus.
Oh.
You got me right?
Yeah.
All right.
Let's do this.
There's a craft right there.
And then you craft in a big mod.
Yeah, I do.
You got this.
Yeah.
This is awkward.
Wait, they're getting shot at.
Yeah, I told you, just craft, you know, and leave.
Craft.
Dude, on your right!
Hello!
What the?
Dude!
That's what you're fucking... That's what you're...
They're dead, they're dead!
This is round three!
They're dead!
No, you cute!
I'm gonna go!
Bro!
I want you to watch them die!
No, they died by default.
We won by default I can't believe it.
I can't fucking...
You didn't see that?
Oh, that's a cool ass of the name.
can't believe it we could have saw this i can't believe we
won we won by default don't worry brad honestly true true
true they die that means we won automatically yeah yeah we
won we won easy you know you're right you're right it was
easily ggs anyway that's crazy i can't believe they threw
and they could have They just didn't go to his own.
They could have, yeah.
That's all they had to do.
Yeah, we won, chat.
Yeah, we won.
No more better.
We won the mental game.
The mental game.
Yeah, we won the mental warfare.
Mentally, I am not here.
True!
Mentally, I'm in Tarkov.
Bro, you're still playing that scam game.
No, I haven't touched it in like...
Look, see you fucking bought that 50% shit and then you're
fucking playing.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit with the hood.
Okay, I'm landing here.
I have a wingy.
Alright, I have a wingy, I have a flat life.
Don't die.
That's all I can say.
Just don't die.
Or is that guy gonna leave?
Oh, I might be dead though.
I have my...
Yeah, our guy left.
Oh, I got led.
What the fuck?
Hey, I'm missing all my...
No!
I flesh, flesh, flesh.
Oh, no.
I got flesh.
Don't worry, I shield you.
I got you.
What are you doing, bro?
Oh, my God!
Wait.
Don't die like this.
Okay, that was sick.
There's 19.
Okay.
I expected that from a far away.
That was cool.
I expected that from far, far away.
You died a cream de la pussy.
I broke his knees.
Oh my god.
That was cool though.
I expected that so much.
That was that back and forth.
Yo, there's a second team.
There's a second team.
There is.
We landed with like four teams.
Oh my god.
I mean, you clutched it.
you clutched it and then you died well that's a win in my
book yeah oh shit whoa whoa okay he must have a shotgun ball
there's no way that swap was so fast to see that that's that
was such a fucking fast swap man i have been streaming apex
for three days straight have i were you actually streamed a
really i thought you know you played finals finals there's
apex and then apex and then a break and then apex at night
and then apex and then now you apex yay i mean it shows it
it shows that you're warmed up well probably it's mostly
stupidity because it's just the boys oh because you guys are
playing rank right yeah we were yeah that's all your goals
so someone someone challenged us well someone challenged my
teammate yeah, if you reach Masters, someone's gonna buy him
like a scuff controller or something like that, I don't
know.
But yeah, why does he want a controller?
Because he's a controller player.
I don't know.
Oh, wait, no, tell him to get him a battle beaver.
What's that?
I don't do controller.
That's like the controller that everybody use, like all the
pros uses.
Oh, for real.
Yeah.
Let him know that.
Yeah, I know because I bought one and I never used it.
yeah i know we just met but i could tell you'd do that you'd
do that wait so like he needs to be masters to get that yeah
but that's so fucking easy i know right yeah wait what what
rank is he now gold one i guess we stopped because i need to
sleep how long has he wait how many days left till rank is
over i'm not sure actually i'm pretty sure it's like not
that Like, there's still a long time, right?
Ranked to start.
Guys, how many more days till Rank is over?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I got fricked up.
Oh, wait, I'm here.
I'm coming over.
JK, I'm looting.
I'm looting right now.
You guys are fine, right?
He has 26 days, bro.
That's so easy.
Yeah, there's a lot.
Yeah, you can literally get that in, like, like, two weeks.
We got this.
Like, literally two weeks you can get Masters.
That's so fucking easy.
Ah, no, no, no, no.
what you guys need i can't i can't trade for some reason
okay there's a team on the other side yeah that's why i
wanted to go there i don't see them though but i know they
landed there where are they where the fuck are they they're
all over there pension look look with your eyes tell me
where they are i am squinty as shit look with your eyes oh
true you're Asian so am I we are all so am I all right don't
worry I'm coming over I'm coming over oh I want to go
through that too wait where are they what the fuck I didn't
finish you on this guy accidentally where are you sure hello
there you go Oh, we're right there below.
Blush?
JK?
What?
Hail.
I'm being shot by another squad!
Behind you, behind you.
Behind us?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, there's a wingman here.
You want it?
Hold on.
I'll take it.
Yeah, I'll...
Oh, that's going to save.
You need it there.
Here's right there.
I don't think they're pushing me.
There's no way they're pushing.
They're too scared.
I don't think I'll switch the loom in just yet.
Okay, I don't see them.
I don't see them.
You're looting Lobos.
Yeah, let's just head over.
Yeah.
All right.
We're doing this?
Yeah, of course.
Are you scared?
No.
Yeah, don't be a little bitch.
When did you become a little bitch?
Yeah.
Yeah, you're not a little, tell the world you're not a
little bitch.
okay he's a little bitch no i'm too tired i've been awake
since two man what the fuck you're like he's super low oh
yeah he's dead nice he's dead too wait where did his
teammate go did he run you got this you got this i'm
thirsting I'm watching you Yeah see You almost fucking died
Here's a kill drone Yep That's a little embarrassing Yeah
hey I punched him like a man I showed myself I am no beach
Yeah didn't you miss No I didn't Oh you didn't Oh I thought
you missed That's why you punched him Well I ran out of ammo
Talk to grandpa that way Grandpa is like a hardened like war
veteran he can take it uh he can take it he can take this
he's used to it yes yes the worst was my wife my ex-wife she
uh but i thought you're level 100 wizard she divorced me as
soon as the same day as we got married You save it for
marriage, right?
Is that what you're trying to plot?
Okay, golden triple take.
Wah!
It's gone.
Hey, hey, hey, stop shooting me, stop shooting me.
I'm heading over here.
Got an accessory.
Wait, they're white armor.
For real?
Yeah, why are you scared?
They're literally...
Wah.
Yeah, they're white armor.
that's a break
bunch of them yeah babies they're actual babies
is he just by himself or what I don't fucking know I'm
fucking stealing a shit what no he was there was a
bloodhound I think the bloodhound ran for why oh no they're
white armor when you think why literally shot me and they
see purple oh there you are wait this guy's actually a baby
he's right here he's flesh you can literally kill him well
this guy's an actual child
do you kill it so you actually killed a child in game my
specialty wait your specialty wait how many children More
than my fingers.
Alright.
Seven more teams.
Alright, what are your plans for streams when you debut?
Dungeon, what plan are you doing?
I honestly have no clue.
My plan is!
I'm only here to fuck around and find out and have fun.
What do you guys want to see him stream?
Guys.
They want to see me naked and that's the problem.
Wait, is that true?
Yeah.
Guys, you can't see him naked.
You gotta marry him first.
That's why.
That's one big super chat.
Chat, you can't see him naked, guys.
Wait, will you marry all of your chat then?
What?
If they want to see him naked.
Huh?
But I'm shy.
Well, that's why you're...
That's why you got divorced.
Oh,
my God.
Oh.
Oh, man.
I got divorced one day.
Poor God.
Me.
Damn, it's okay, man.
It's okay, bro.
It's just...
shut up I don't want to hear that from you bro it's okay bro
everything will be okay bro I ain't hearing that one day
it's okay being level 101 wizard it's also cool oh oh
there's enemies in front of me too don't care about that guy
yeah don't care about we can but our team is a youtuber
don't care don't care about him we can craft he's a youtuber
he's from YouTube it's Listen.
There was a res in front of me.
Should I make him a nexus?
No, what the fuck?
He's gotta learn.
He'll never learn.
We just rotated the whole lot of stuff.
Yeah, but we saw a res.
It's okay.
We saw a res.
So like, it was worth it.
And also we're going to zone.
We're just trying to find people.
Okay.
I'm on autopilot.
but all right i'm climbing up stop bullying small content
creators tension tension i'm a small content creator no and
i'm not gonna say that like of course i know yeah i'm sure
you know that yeah but like i'm here to give you courage i'm
not bullying you right i'm inspiring you right I'm inspiring
you right now.
Oh my god.
What is this lag?
Are you okay?
No, I'm not okay.
I had like the most insane lag, Evie.
That was actually crazy.
That lag was insane.
Where did it go?
Did it stop peeking?
Wait, where?
They're right there.
I'm going to take my package here.
god that lag was actually crazy i can't no i can't oh my god
poor guys poor guys like what the fuck is going on this guy
lagged oh my god we have 500 ping that's actually crazy wait
what i do is actually there's two teams there's two teams
okay okay i did something to that poor lifeline and like i
feel bad what i did to him
oh my god i hit these but like it doesn't register i'm gonna
go to the right whoa our guard's pushing oh he's fucking
crazy then you're crazy i mean there's two teams yeah still
i'm gonna heal let me climb uh he's on the roof what
someone's on the roof that's My shot's gonna hit like three
seconds later.
Someone land.
Their armor is at hell.
That no way.
Oh my.
How am I at 500 ping?
This is the worst gun to have to be lagging with.
Wait, there's people behind us.
Oh, I'm heading over here.
I'll head to my guy.
Okay, I stopped lagging there, Lee.
I'm gonna fucking you think I won't I have so much ammo No,
please please don't he don't do this to me No Be fine,
right?
Yeah, see I knew it Whoa, we gotta go to zone though surely
I'm heading over to zone Sure right below oh in front of us
it's there they're so far though They are.
What do we do?
I broke their thing, so now they're scared.
We're gonna head to zone.
Someone's resing?
Okay, I'm gonna head to the far right.
I'm gonna head to the tunnels.
It's not.
Yeah, they're just gonna camp us out.
Let's head to the tunnels.
It's not worth it.
Not worth it.
The zone is closing anyway, so...
Wait, can we make it?
Wait, I don't even know if we can make it to the tunnels.
Can we... No, we can't.
We actually can't.
We have to go like...
Wait.
Do we have to?
I can't make that.
Yeah, we can't.
Okay, I'm going to have to go here.
I'm going to go.
I'm just going to go here then.
Are guys fighting?
Wait, what?
One last squad?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got this for you guys.
Wait, we have your cue.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we have your cue to rotate.
Alright.
Go ahead.
Climb up.
What a rest.
out of here
i'm climbing up oh not climbing up anymore i'm taking your
portal oh my god what oh my god oh my god they're blasting
me nope now you can't we can't maybe just camp that place oh
jesus christ what happened i have no clue what happened to
you guys what you tied so I don't know that was that was bad
All eyes were on me I literally went up the portal And
everything was just gone
Oh my god I thought I was behind a pole And I was safe Yeah
you were just You were just gone Yeah Man You like literally
got deleted so fast that's apex
oh it's okay it's all right we're gonna win this next one
because we're better oh hey we all did pretty well hey dad
youtuber guy did pretty good he was not dead wait he's all
right yeah guys he was not dead wait he did it we got a
random that actually did stuff
Good on him.
Good for him.
Why is the queue in taking so long?
Yay.
Apparently, like, I tweeted out that, like, I joined a cool
religion.
Apparently, cool in, like, I guess, like, Brazilian is ass.
So I technically tweeted out, I joined an ass religion
today.
All my, like, Brazilian dragoons are really confused.
I never knew you were an ass person.
I was like wondering why there's so much Brazilian comments.
Shhh.
Oh shit, it's King China.
Fah!
Why did I play Alter?
Why did I go Alter?
Ah, damn.
Yeah, so apparently people were like...
Why are you, why are you saying ask?
So how did you join the ask hold?
And like, where do I sign up, you know?
Did you tear it open or what?
Oh my god.
Whoops.
I mean it works still.
It works still.
Yeah, it's Portuguese.
Apparently, I don't even know how it's pronounced.
But, like, someone in my comments, the replies were like,
oh, the Brazilian dragoons are coming.
And I got so confused.
I got so fucking confused.
I was like, why?
And then I saw it.
It's silent and deadly religion.
And I was, and then I saw, like, I guess I saw Portuguese in
my chat, like, in my replies.
And I was like, why is there so much Portuguese?
right now going on in my replies like well now you know
what's going on bro i miss uh oh wait there is is there team
on us not really i think i'm not sure there shouldn't be
doki come to brazil and have a brazilian convention invite
me guys i'm down i want to go to brazil Like, virtually?
You're going to Brazil.
Virtually?
Tell your local...
Not local, tell your conventions, your big anime conventions
to invite me to Brazil.
I'll come to Brazil.
Bro.
Indo when?
I don't know, Indo when.
Benjamin, you're the one that has the connections.
Hey, man.
I tried linking you up.
Yo.
Okay, look, look.
They just, okay, to be fair, that's on me because, like, I
didn't reply back to, like, the email.
No, they didn't send me.
They didn't send me the new email.
I was waiting for the new email, but, like, it wasn't sent.
That's, like, not fully on me.
You have a lot of faith.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Guys, guys.
I'm your help.
Guys, guys, here.
I got distracted by Brazil.
I got distracted.
I blame Tengen.
What?
You distracted me?
Yeah, that's why.
Now you're dead.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, you're fucking dead.
We got the caustic.
No, our caustic is still...
Whoa!
Wait, he got down.
He got down.
Oh, wait, wait.
Wait, he can do this.
He's better.
He can.
He's so much better.
Someone's resing.
Yeah, it's the guy that our guy fucking...
Okay, he's not that better.
You're never mind.
He's not that much better.
Look, maybe I'll be there at an Indonesian convention.
I just need, you know, attention to...
Attention, tell them to email me.
On it.
Yeah.
I told you to tell them to email me, and you just, like,
replied back to the old email.
Yeah, but like it's the old email.
I need to It doesn't matter.
Yes, it does.
Because it's the old one.
All right, all right.
Because that date was gone.
I'll try to set it up.
We have a lot of fans in Indonesia.
Yeah.
Any Indo-brows?
Indo-brows, rise up.
Rise up.
I'm one of them.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, the one that's...
Yeah, yeah, he's membered now, right?
Yeah, yeah.
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's my biggest fan oh
yeah that's our story right yeah you were like the biggest
joki fan and then we bumped and then we bumped into each
other i forgot her story almost we bumped into like each
other like uh in apex and he was like fan girling me hard
and he was like oh my god you're the real joki bird i've
been following you for my god is that joki bird yeah that's
what he said in like voice chat and And then I blocked him.
And then...
Yeah, pretty much what happened.
Yeah, and then I blocked him because I was like, ugh.
Indeed.
I was just like, oh my god.
That was so real.
I'm fucked.
They landed there, really?
I don't have a gun.
You don't have a gun.
I have one gun.
You know, like, they made a thing where you loot a pill.
They automatically give you a gun when you first land.
Oh, shit.
Are they following us?
Oh, fuck.
No, I don't have a gun.
Hey, oh my god.
Oh, I'm gonna rotate.
If you guys die, it's on you.
Oh, there's guns here.
I'm fine.
They're scared now.
They're scared.
I literally can barely see them, but they're scared.
I'm gonna put...
Nice.
Yay!
Okay.
What a wingman?
No, I found a turbo charger.
I have...
Oh wait, they're fighting.
The worst she could say was no.
She wish she could what?
Someone said like the worst thing she could say is no.
Nah.
There's more than that.
Oh yeah?
You have experience?
What else?
I'd rather not talk about it.
Nah.
Oh no, trauma.
Yep.
I'm gonna go for mine.
We brought complex.
I'm from below.
I need help.
Flesh?
I'm fighting, I'm also fighting someone.
Oh crap.
I got one.
Oh god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I need to swap.
No!
There!
I gotta kill someone!
I'm fighting my demons, I'm telling you.
Oh my god!
I'm fighting fighting your demons right now!
He's up there.
He's up top.
He's up top?
Still?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why?
I don't know.
I think I can read his sick one.
Oh, he hates you.
He's fucking BMing you.
Now you have to win.
So you can shit-talk him after.
Oh, you proved this point!
You proved it!
Yeah, goddam all...
damn you got called out yeah you got fucking called out bro
it doesn't matter lots of trash in a sheet oh man what do
you think about rival rival is so far i very laggy because
there's no agent yeah yeah there's a thing honestly i could
i'm trying to enjoy it wouldn't there it's just too laggy
yeah it's true for the movements it's so too much oh my god
have you tried spider-man that fucking shit was crazy i
maimed spider-man why why would you do that to yourself hey
the wall run the wall run is fun yeah but it was like i
tried to play spider-man i was like like i wanted to throw
up you got a combo with it you got a combo the motion it was
so bad like you gotta combo it come on i thought you were
good at fps games what oh yeah yeah the fucking spider-man
melee the fps games yeah yeah yeah attention so true first
punching shooter so fucking true exactly where's our guy
gonna take us sir we're gonna take bro he's level 14 wait
this guy's a baby Yeah, he's level 14.
Whoa, we're dropping in a shit on a shit.
Hell, no, I'm not dropping on a shit.
Wait, is he actually trying to get to the shit?
He's trying to get to the shit.
At least he was.
And then he didn't reach it.
For he's level 14, of course he's not.
Hey.
Oh, boy.
Is there anyone near us?
Probably not.
Yeah, I'm going to say that drop was terrible.
That drop was a level.
14 drop like oh my god that was terrible let's go head to
labs oh i hear people fighting i'm heading over to the fight
uh where are you where are you tension what movement
movement weird i'm going man i'm going i'm going going i
might be a little stupid oh i know hey at least it's
something you know even if it's stupid oh i need help yes
i'm right here holy yeah i definitely need help oh he's one
oh that's you okay i have to i have to do Yeah, see, I knew
you got this.
Wait, where's his teammate?
Oh, his teammate's coming!
Oh, his teammate has no armor.
Okay.
That was embarrassing for him.
Uh-huh.
His teammate has no more ammo, like, armor at all.
Yay!
Wanna use that?
What?
What ultimates why?
This is not rank tangent Oh, yeah, it's not rank.
Who the fuck care?
I have PTSDs who the fuck yeah, I have PTSDs.
Yeah, I could tell like I'm just like why we literally have
like like the alt shit right here, too Really have the
charge towers like what the fuck?
I keep forgetting our nine is dog shit now.
It sucks.
Yeah Yeah, same.
Yeah, I keep fucking...
Uh, I can't...
I need to like swap my gun.
My scroll wheel is double clicking and that is the most
annoying part that I'm having.
Is your mouse broke?
Yeah, I really want to fix it, but then I'm lazy.
What do you mean, just buy a mouse?
Yeah, just...
You and your stuff.
What do you mean?
If it's broken?
Man.
Hey man, I can fix it.
Did you forget where I'm from a third world country?
Oh, true, true.
It's crazy.
Just go out and buy it so that you don't have to worry about
customs.
Go through the jungle and then go through the jungle and
then go through the jungle.
There has to be mouse stores, right?
Miss money bags.
No, he's talking about customs.
He's not talking about like not being afforded.
It's talking about customs because like Indonesian customs.
is like terrible when it comes to shipping stuff yes yeah
even though like you know you declare it oh it's a gift and
they're like no stunt yeah so like and then you get like
taxed or whatever right yeah isn't it i'm calling them out
legit what are they gonna do like send somebody over they're
gonna they're gonna charge me for something attention
doesn't show up for his own happen like even if there's
documents like declaring this is a gift gift cannot be like
you know you can't charge that and they're like no it's not
a gift you got this yeah so just go out and go out and just
can you go out and like buy buy a mouse mouse can you just
do that like i don't even know to buy now just fucking get a
g pro wireless that's like the classic i mean that's the
classic like never i'm using i mean i'm using a g pro
wireless yeah but aren't you like isn't your g pro wireless
fucking up right now only the scroll wheel i can change the
switches yeah but like i did the other with the other clicks
like you're just gonna change your bindings i should i no i
soldered it oh like i tear it apart i soldered my oh man
that's so much work I swapped it with a better switch.
Yeah, but like, it's so much easier to just...
Doesn't have that mushy click when I bought it on day one.
But it's so much easier to just, you know...
Wait, to our left?
There's people to my right.
Someone's dropping over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's a full team.
I think they saw me.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure...
Wait, what the fuck?
There's another team here.
Right there.
saw you man i think i think i think they saw me too i think
i think i think i think they saw you i think they saw me
dude we're fucked oh i think they saw both of you dude we're
fucked there's two teams there's two teams i think we're
fucked bro there's two teams i think we're both i think
we're both you guys uh-huh i don't think they saw me right
no hey yep They wouldn't they wouldn't they wouldn't see you
they wouldn't see you how would they know I don't know they
don't know they don't know they don't know they don't know
They wouldn't know they would know I got away for so long I
got away for so long So they did know no no they're hacking
no they're hacking there's no way for it shit there's no way
It's like IP ban.
Hardware ban.
What?
Is somebody super chat for you to get a mouse?
More or less.
Courtesy of the Dragoon.
Somebody was like, what the fuck?
That's crazy.
Mouse fun.
Go fucking get a better mouse.
yeah but like i could fix this you and how long you've been
having this problem um just like two months bro what the
fuck when did you i could fix this yeah wife why fix when
can buy no okay yeah that's that's my motto
That's what I do.
That's what you do.
Why fix when I can just buy?
Because I can fix it.
And I can't buy it.
It's so much work.
Monetarily wise?
Yeah.
I guess I can buy it.
But then I'll just change the switch immediately.
You're not even, yeah, and then you can sell the old one.
yeah pre-loved signed oh my god you just you can you can do
that now you can auction off your i you know what you could
you sign the mouse and then you auction it off but but like
i i do have to point out the disclaimer it doesn't come with
my skills i mean i don't think that's what they want from
that i mean you don't know my fans i think other stuff is
gonna be done no no no i think done with your mouth.
Eww!
What do you mean, ew!
It's like a collection!
Eww!
Yeah, it comes with the it comes with the gamer sweat.
What skills, indeed, I don't have one!
The gamer sweat.
Yeah, it just comes with my sweat, and that's it.
Yeah, and then...
Oh yeah, they like that, what the fuck?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
The hell?
That sounds like they're not, they're not buying it for the
skills.
Put the mouse in the what?
A jar.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, but tension.
Think about the amount of money you'll get.
Think about it.
No.
You know, you know, it's tempting.
You know, it's tempting.
No.
You know, you should auction it off.
Yeah, but and then if it's signed too.
What the fuck?
I'm just...
I'm just helping Tengen make money.
What do you mean?
Dude.
Wait, what's that?
You're fighting someone?
Bro, this guy, I think this guy's special.
Do you just go around and call people special?
No, you should have seen what I just saw.
Okay.
You should have seen what I saw.
You literally stood there to get shot at for, like, at least
five seconds.
right here.
He's definitely special.
Don't hit him.
I'm trying to figure out.
Do you know where they are?
I can't see them.
Like, below me?
Hey.
You'll be fine?
Ha!
Oh, you'll be fine?
Oh, you got them.
There's his teammate, though.
I'm in the sky waiting.
Surely.
Does he have heavy ammo?
Is this a special guy?
I almost killed?
No.
No, it's not.
Let me know you're fine.
Oh wait, I hear him.
I know you guys find heavy ammo.
Oh, there he is.
Oh Was that the special kid?
Um, what did he do?
What did he do?
This...
What happened?
What the fuck did he do?
What?
Okay, he blasted the whole Spitfire at me and didn't hit a
single one.
I am like shotgun ranged, man.
That might have been him.
Oh my god.
I told you.
He's special.
Oh wait, wait.
From my right, I see the sniper.
Oh wait, he's actually hitting you.
Nice scream.
Please stop.
I'm scared.
Okay, Valkyrie.
okay I don't know where his teammates are like this guy's
definitely wait I'm gonna shot from a second cross I'm gonna
shot from a cross am I right oh nice all right yeah this
feels like feels like singapore servers the different ranges
of fucking skills in this lobby yeah yeah this is how it
goes down here yeah the wow that's for sure I saw the valg
the valg literally just like fucking like m1 flew to my face
and I'm like okay I mean, okay.
Like, that's the play.
I'm gonna fucking grab the armor shit.
So I want to have that care package.
That next airline, the next lifeline care package.
That's an airline package.
Hey.
Another squad, what?
Is there?
Oh, the slip line.
Isn't it supposed to be like that one?
oh okay yeah two golden triple taking one squad i don't get
what they're doing but hey where are they where are they
tension it's king's canyon i'm not sure tension where are
they over there where's there there wait are they actually
wait oh my god they are what the fuck how did you see it oh
he's dead oh goodbye yeah out of the amen Get out of there.
Goodbye.
Get out of there, bro.
Bro, get out of there.
Come over, come over.
I'm leaving the zip line.
Get out of there.
I don't...
I think he also is a little special too.
Oh,
you saw that now.
Yep.
Take it, take it, sit.
Don't take it sit, don't take it sit, don't take it sit.
Oh, shit, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Cover me, cover me.
What do you mean?
No, I'm not.
I can't believe you guys just let them do that to me That's
fucked up Okay, Tengen, do not Tengen, no He's so low, why
is it he's doing?
He's just here Bro, I hit two shots Oh no Dude, legit They
res, they res Oh no, they res I hear heard the res Oh my
god, he's jumping over He's on the roof, he's Spider-Manning
Oh, crap He's on the roof, Tengen Oh, crap Oh my god, the
bloodhounds coming over too.
Okay, you have to make sure the lifeline doesn't res him.
You gotta heal, you gotta heal.
Where is my friend?
He's over there, he's over there.
I'm watching.
I'm watching, I'm watching.
Oh my god, the lifeline's resing, the lifeline's resing!
Blow your attention!
Bro, where is my friend?
Bro, he's special, okay?
Yeah, he missed?
Okay.
You should really, oh no.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, no.
I should I was I'm spraying left and right Oh my he's he's
dead he said he said I have I have I have fucked up I I felt
I okay I would admit I have aneurysm I would admit I did do
something a little special today
I'm gonna have a stroke I swear I'm blessed like three mags
to people two people are low my friends behind just charging
himself oh my god oh my god that was uh we have a bot oh
it's okay we it's okay i just i got a little bit too you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna actually i'm gonna play the
game you're gonna actually you're gonna actually play the
game i'm actually playing the game i've been autopiloting as
well the whole time
i'm gonna actually play the game this time she's actually
playing oh my god this is it there's no way this is it i
didn't know you play bangalore oh my god really oh yeah you
just met me so you
Yeah, right.
You just found out.
Uh-huh.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna show you.
Yeah, what do you play?
Dungeon?
What do I play?
Yeah, who do you mean?
Hmm.
Shit, who did I mean?
I just fail.
I fail.
I'll be honest.
I have no boundaries of who to play and what to play.
Really?
Yeah.
And you used to play something before?
what was it you have like you used to play how do you
mention it before to me when we jet when we met like a
couple of days ago new castle yeah sure oh my god there's 20
people on me there's 20 people on me yeah because you have a
goddamn trail on your way oh my what that's a whole There's
20 people on my ass!
Oh, my god.
Okay, I am okay.
Wait, what?
I can't click.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, behind you, behind you, behind you,
behind you, behind you.
There's another guy to our right as well.
I'm just gonna walk away.
But you can rush me against this door.
It'll be safe.
Where are you?
Right here?
Wait, it's okay.
Our guys are going to rush me.
Wait, wait, wait, there's more.
Yeah, our guys.
No.
Oh, no.
No, I'm a fucking athoris.
What?
Ah!
Oh god.
There's more B-bone!
Bro, I fucking...
No, I said there's a lot!
Why did we land here?
You!
I was not Jumpmaster!
Oh yeah, you was not.
You got this.
Where is he?
Right there.
Okay, they're fighting each other.
They're fighting each other.
No way.
You're not doing this.
Are you?
No.
They're right.
Oh, God.
No, he can't!
Oh!
Swap!
Oh, my God!
Bro!
I'm in that moment.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, he waited!
Okay, that was pretty gamer though.
That was pretty gamer, you gotta admit.
Yeah, that is awesome.
That was sick.
Honestly, that was clean.
But the timing could not have been better, but that got out.
That was pretty fucking clean.
I hit all those shots that I needed to hit there.
Holy shit.
That was awesome.
Yeah, that was pretty clean.
If only our fucking our guy still had his shield.
I think I could have clutched it, but the rampart shit
fucked him up Rampart shit was too good Oh my god, okay
Tengen, we can't end until we win Tengen.
We're gonna be here forever.
We're ending it.
We can't end.
Yeah Now what's that?
Funny word.
Yeah, we don't end until I win All right, let's be serious.
Oh, now you want to be serious.
Hell yeah.
Wow.
All right, here we go.
I told you I was playing for real.
Yeah, we're playing for real now.
Yeah, I told you guys.
We're playing for real.
For real, for reals.
Yeah.
For gamers.
That boy is ready to sleep, to be fair.
He like before we started the stream, he was like, oh man,
my fucking stomach.
Yeah, I needed to shit.
He drank coffee before the stream, guys.
Are you still drinking?
No, I'm good.
Dude, I'm drinking water.
Okay.
Yeah, he stayed.
He like woke up the wrong time, even though I reminded him
the time.
like and he saw my schedule and he still forgot the actual
time no my game crash no oh no I thought this is server your
game no oh my god oh my god please keep me alive keep me
alive yes you can you're in the worst place possible no it's
not that bad I swear it's not that bad tension I swear we'll
be okay we'll be okay am I dead am I dead No.
Okay, just keep guard.
They won't expect it because I'm standing still so it's like
I'm like part of the nature.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear you.
It's part of the nature.
Okay, please tell me I'm still alive, Tengen.
You are, you are.
Okay.
I'm in.
Whoa!
Oh my god, I am safe.
Holy shit.
How did you get me all the way here?
There's a whole team inside of you.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
Oh, maybe worry a little bit.
Wait, there's another team!
Oh my god!
I'm dead.
There's already another team.
Look, man.
We're pretty much after.
Oh no, I'm still okay.
We're not gonna look here.
You're good, right?
Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
No, I'm not.
Because there's two thieves.
I'm okay.
there's, like, on the wall right now on the roof.
I don't know.
I'm...
See, I told you I'm okay.
Oh, you're so not okay Tengen.
I'm dead.
You are so fucking...
Wait, keep crawling, keep crawling.
Keep crawling.
Oh, you got this.
Yeah, I told you.
Keep crawling, keep crawling, keep crawling.
You'll be all right?
No?
No!
What?
Who are you?
Give us smoke, give us smoke, no?
I do.
So like, literally I'm one hit.
I'm literally one hit.
Okay.
What the fuck are these people?
Oh my god.
Where did these guys come from?
It was definitely not okay.
I was not okay.
Yeah.
How did your game crash?
I don't know.
I got like some weird error code.
read it fully because i was like what the fuck is this
erico's that's a weird as okay there was like four five four
fucking teams here there was so oh my god there is like four
it's okay the guy that killed me died that's all that
matters they don't deserve it i hope they don't they don't
deserve they don't deserve anything paid actor oh my god
literally came out of nowhere what the fuck what is that
horizon doing or talus what's happening with this team the
hell i thought you were gonna focus up what happened you
crashed okay i i crashed but i was still alive i wanted i
wanted to push someone and then my game crashed oh wait
you're a crash dude see no no no i'm good i'm good i'm good
i'm good just be here haha i
was gonna say
this time this time surely surely surely there's no way
there's no way i just slapped myself if we lose i don't know
why but hey if we don't win this next game wait no because
then you want to lose no i won't i won't trust me if we win
this game if we win this game i'll super chat tangent what
wait what nah nah you can't do this to me why are you giving
me pressure and expectations which i never really had i can
do something really fucked up i can be like The super shot
starts at 500, like, not five, 100.
And then every loss, it loses $10.
What?
Who are you, Mr. Beast?
You Mr. Beast era?
We double or nothing.
But instead of giving money, I take it away.
Where are they?
They're in this building.
Oh, I see them.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, I got shot by... Oh, good luck, Tangian.
Mr. Beast.
Tangian, good luck.
Tangian, think about the money.
He's rising in front of you.
you have to win we have to win this as a duo now what no
it's still a hundred it's still one akka we're the dokey
beast fun dokey beast funds i got someone's like throwing to
pay like they're just throwing in they're just throwing in a
pot i didn't expect to get shot by three fucking people like
what the fuck how do you expect me to live i was like what
the i mean i don't even know what our teammate was doing
honestly it's true i don't know either like like like they
just waited there oh okay oh i like it every 10 every kill
gets ten dollars assists don't count someone's flying here
let's go oh shit Already?
Yep.
Oh, he's serious now.
The lifeline's on you.
Oh my god!
No, he's won!
Oh, he's resing.
Below you.
Yeah.
You go, well, I can't do anything, can I?
Oh, no.
Pension, I think you should just leave.
I don't know, ma'am.
Oh Girl is running out over here on me What the fuck is
wrong with you The heck all right Man, where is our trio?
I don't know bro Okay, I won't throw I won't throw this
time.
Oh, this is you Chris you fucking did that's my that's my
friend You have to have an Aka.
Bro!
Bro, you fucking, you're a bitch!
Chris, you fuck!
It's Aka Supa!
You!
You sick fuck!
I swear to God, you sick fuck!
Chris, you sick fuck!
Oh my god, your friend was like, no Aka Supa for you!
Crazy!
That's actually like crazy!
That's crazy!
That's a pro right now.
there that's a that's a pro right there oh that's a son of a
bitch bro costed him ten dollars
okay now you're 90 dollars but every kill is at ten dollars
every kill is ten dollars oh my god i feel like mr beast
right now i have no the dokey beast I'm gonna, like, if I
stranded you on an island, would you do it?
Bro, he's sniping us and trying to be in the same party as
us, but I'm not gonna kill you, bro.
Nah, bro.
Hell.
You betrayed me.
You have betrayed me.
You're like, bro, I need this.
I shall take your mod title.
Yeah, remove his mod title.
He just hands it.
Bro, you fucking took your $10.
it was that's crazy it's up bro you're stealing buddy bro
when he also stealing isn't he also indo yeah he is down
you're stealing it from a fellow indonesian bro you're first
you you steal my money and i never had rights to begin with
that was my one way ticket to having rights man
damn i'm fucked up bro that's fucked up man bro took the
rights he's like if i can't be on your team then you don't
deserve money hell bro is praying from my downfall i'm gonna
check out the map room wait there's people here there's
people here wait is there no i was lying i was i mean we
could just we could scan the radar yeah i was lying i was
just paranoid that's it uh-huh see i'm gonna grab your
friend oh no oh no i'm seeing things oh i'm not even here
this has been the solo stream i actually changes my secret
account imaginary friend yeah okay someone scanned us just
now they're here Yep.
Don't worry, I'm serious now.
They know I'm literally right here.
Got one.
Oh shit.
Wow, ever since I gave him an incentive, he's actually
killing everybody.
That's actually crazy.
So where's his teammate?
Did you get another one?
Oh my god.
Whoa, who's behind?
Whoa, he went from behind.
Let him rise.
Wait, where?
okay he doesn't res me i don't know where he's going it's
fine he's almost dead is he actually still not resing you no
there there's a 10 for you
bro oh he's a youtuber no wonder he's trying to get clips
yeah he's trying to get clips bro yeah he's trying to get
clips for his uh promoting channel yeah yeah yeah yeah we
should take clips away from him you guys deserve it yeah
we're also growing you should ask him you should ask him
yeah yo you want ten dollars yeah you want ten dollars just
pay him off i did you want five dollars okay we could split
this off man you want ten dollars in ruin tangents game
again So he loses another 10.
Hail.
It's like that.
It's like, you remember that story of that parent that like
paid like an online bounty hunter and where like that guy,
like he hired somebody to like purposely assassinate his
son's character.
And so he'll like stop playing video games.
Oh man.
That's going to be me.
That's going to be me too.
what dude okay he's just trying to be thoughtful and i'll be
like red purposely let's see just trying to be thoughtful
i'm gonna do with this well you never heard of that story
before i have yeah oh okay i just want to know that that's
to me one to me yeah that's the end of that yeah what's your
friend's name classy fucking where is he chris chris okay
chris are you in this game chris you want ten dollars you
want ten dollars from from ten to his balance he said nah
you'll do it for free no because you'll do it he doesn't
need a 10 dollar yeah hell the hell bro's chilling he says
that's fucked up he literally killed you for free did he
yeah legit he had no purpose no reason no reason to be there
uh no oh he's not in the game No, he's not in the game.
If he was, he'd be ready.
He probably would.
I could tell.
There should be a team in front of us.
I saw, like, from your scan.
Or from Red scan.
Oh, in front of us, in front of us.
How are we doing this?
I don't know.
It's your $10.
What?
Oh, yeah.
I'm getting paid.
Yeah.
Real this time?
That was our deal.
oh i got one of those kills oh they're wiped that fully
wiped oh we did it nice easiest ten dollars of your life
there's a whole why i i altered for nothing yeah but think
about that ten dollars though think of that mr d's dollars
legit some dollars and where i live that's like three weeks
Oh, true.
That's actually true.
That's three weeks of food.
Wait, really?
If you find your place right, yeah.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Other than, I guess like the only trade-off is that like
customs fucking suck.
Yeah, well.
You know, I'm $10 richer.
I can almost say that.
Yeah, only if you win this game though.
What?
Yeah.
It applies to your winning the game.
What?
So it doesn't...
A 20 bomb plus the win.
All right, I grabbed some armor.
$10 is $10.
Honestly, yeah.
Weather kind of suck.
Was the weather suck?
Why?
It's hot.
It's been like...
I mean, that's Asian in general, though.
Is that just Asian?
Yeah.
they don't see us they don't see us okay now they might know
now they definitely know they still have net no no no no no
that is yeah yeah i'm gonna look over them and they're gonna
look okay now they know okay okay they have to know they
have to okay they definitely know what how was that oh my
god dude this guy's a baby this guy's actually a baby holy
that guy's a baby there's no way we just kill the child
Oh my god, we actually killed a child.
Where's his teammate?
In the game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
My lawyer advises me.
Nice.
I got the kill.
In the game.
Once again.
We don't want to repeat.
Okay, but do you see that bloodhound?
You are so confused.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm gonna get healed real fast.
To my left.
Why?
Don't leave.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Wait, he didn't get hit?
He's so low!
Knocked him?
Where's his teammate?
Bye!
Give me your loot.
You'll be fine, right?
Surely.
Oh, no, there's another team.
There's another team?
Oh, wait, there's another team above, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm bailing.
Where's the other...
Where's his teammate, then?
Shit.
They're scared.
Wait, I hear him.
To my left.
Yeah, yeah, he's in here.
He's in there.
He went inside.
I didn't get him.
How am I going to say I leaked this?
Whoa!
Red armor?
What?
That?
Don't worry, I got you.
Nice.
They have to come to us.
This team has to come to us.
Hold on, huh?
Like four seconds.
Oh man, dude.
Yeah, they're rolling down.
They're rolling down.
I'm watching.
Sure, right?
I'm just holding them.
Where they at?
My ping?
Oh, there they are.
My ping, my ping.
On me?
Behind us, raw?
Yeah.
Wait, that's like a solo.
Hiding.
There's a solo right there.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
No!
Wait, that's not even a solo.
Ooh, you want that.
You want that.
Wait, where did he go?
Did someone rotated this?
Yeah, they did.
No way.
No kill for you.
No way they rotated that.
That's crazy.
Hey, what the fuck?
All right, one last team.
Uh-huh.
One last team.
One last team, huh?
It would be funny that one team killed us?
That would be so funny.
It'll be so fucking funny, you know it.
Wait.
That's open.
Yeah, we're getting shot by it.
Oh my god!
Would it be funny if I just throw that right now?
Oh, it's over there.
Whoa, where am I getting shot from?
I swear.
What are you something stupid?
It's like they're hitting me mid-airs.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
They're not one.
Where's his teammate?
Wait, his teammate's so far.
They made a nexus.
Oh!
That's dumb.
Tengen wants to get last kill!
Tengen!
Man, they went by a nexus.
That's annoying.
Holy shit.
They made it to Nexus to go back.
Unlucky, Tengen.
You had...
That's crazy.
Unlucky.
Oh, but you got that...
You got...
Okay, but you didn't get other kills.
Okay, that was 90 for the win.
And...
How much?
Whoa, you got seven kills?
Bro, Red Sea.
Red Sea.
Delete your YouTube channel, Red Sea.
That's 160.
What?
Yeah, the 90 on top.
Also, Red Sea, I'm joking.
Don't delete your YouTube channel.
But, like, bro, it's a little embarrassing, bro.
A win?
Yeah, you got a win.
You did it.
How do you feel?
Okay, this is not cigarette money.
I'm kidding.
I'm joking.
Holy shit, I have pocket money, bro.
That's not...
I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God, man.
Okay.
oh yeah i forgot guys don't i forgot i'm not using super
chat we don't want youtube youtube should not be taking this
cut oh yeah youtube takes yeah yeah yeah that's why i was
like you're not taking a tangent cigarette money you're not
oh man see that's not so hard nah it's not so easy game see
look at that like if you I think if you didn't get streams
night by your your friend you could have won the last game I
think 100% not really there's two oh no there you go easy
uh-huh yeah look that's me not cigarette money that's me
thanks for the thanks for the thanks for the thanks for the
boost man
no they're like here's my paypal even though i did more
damage there you know i mean wow thank you dokey beast oh my
god i'm surprised you didn't double or nothing give it to
the next guy give it to the next yeah no no no if i have
some few left maybe don't keep don't keep don't Beast is
here.
Don't worry, guys.
Oh, do you want to be my new one?
Who are the, who is like that the Mr. Beast people?
Like, the guy that's always sticking around with Mr. Beast.
Um...
His gang.
Yeah, his gang.
Who was it?
Are you in, like, my shadow?
Why is there a GIF in the middle?
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
I see.
What is there?
Oh, someone!
I just wanted to see the funny I was like, why is there a
GIF?
gift in the middle the indonesian flag in the middle yeah
you can be my do you want to be my car or chandler yeah you
want to be your chandler you want to be my chandler okay
okay this is chandler tension oh my god don't worry i'm
gonna be the vtuber mr beast here ggs man had a great time
though ggs we're gonna we gotta I play Defiant next week
that's my X Defiant yeah X Defiant looks next week we're
going guys next week together people if you want oh hell
yeah let's do it wait how many people do we need I'm not
sure how much is a full party bro I don't fucking know I
haven't touched that game yet I'll ask around alright yeah
I'm down I'm down GG's bad I have a try hard friend there
for some reason oh yeah people are gonna be so close yeah
Kaz is my brother's name.
I swear if that's actually my little brother donating.
Oh no, no, that's a...
What the fuck is he doing?
That's a dragon.
Kaz is my little bro's name, by the way.
Oh my god, Kaz!
You secretly his little brother?
I didn't realize that!
What was that?
I can't believe it.
Kaz was secretly...
Kaz?
The little dragon?
yeah of course you know the allowance you gave your little
brother it all went back to me i see that's why i'm giving
it back giving it back this whole time no way yeah damn
right oh bless you ggs though a great time
I'm going to go talk to my dragoons now.
I hope you guys enjoyed us playing together for the very
first time on stream.
For the very first time.
Yeah, very first time.
Once again, very first time.
We haven't met until...
I had a very good impression.
Yeah.
Very good impression.
It's not like I...
I found this person on, like, Fiverr to make me...
I totally not put myself on Craigslist to beat something.
I need a collab partner I need a collab partner Who's good
at like FPS games And also to make me look But not good
enough So that I can look good Nope Yeah
What is it, Tanya?
What do you want to say?
But obviously now we didn't do that Yeah, we didn't do that
guys, obviously Like if he's a real person He's a he's a
he's a real person i'm not a paid actor he's not a paid
actor guys totally not behind in contract to say this when i
sent him that 160 we did not plan this guys because it was
not because that 160 dollars was like part of his like
hourly wage for like playing with me it was a real challenge
guys a very real challenge my pits are sweating wait one any
final words tangent before I talk to my dragoons and you
talk to your onjings um thank you and honestly I'm actually
what do you call it I'm in a rush right now oh wait why
because I have to head to a hospital and uh wait what yeah
my My grandfather is like going through a surgery.
Oh, shit.
As of today.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, fuck.
Go do that.
Go.
What the fuck?
Yeah, go freaking do it.
What are you doing here?
An hour later, probably.
So I'll be there.
GG's, man.
GG.
GG's.
All right, I'll see you, dude.
See you next week.
We'll do.
Bye.
oh my god what the that one too real i hope like yeah well
he's just saying an hour so he'll be there and like he says
plenty of time to go to the hospital but yeah that's great
uh connecting with tension let me swap real quick my
chatting screen there you go had a great time um hanging out
with tension today um and just talking about like the most
random shit and just fucking around like he's a real homie
he's a real homie slash bro uh so just felt like you know
just talk about the fucking craziest shit
and just having fun time just saying uh would you hire him
again guys he's a real friend He's a real person.
I did not hire him off of Fiverr and paid him a salary to
make me look good, guys.
He's real.
None of it was scripted, I swear.
All of it was real.
Anyway, guys.
Um.
Um, it was great time.
Um, very long day.
I didn't think I was going to play Rust for so long.
Um, but I actually enjoyed the role-playing.
And, like, it was actually funny.
Like, Will Neff actually followed me back on Twitter, which
I thought was funny.
Which I thought was really nice.
Because, like, I didn't think he would, like, you know,
because he's also, like, a pretty big streamer.
So, like, um, I thought it was really nice that Will Neff
followed me back.
For those who don't know who he was, in Rust, he was, like,
he was Uncle.
He was Uncle...
Uncle...
Billy so yeah uncle baby Billy so um um so that was like a
really fun time um and uh um and I had a great time on both
rest and apex today uh I think tomorrow is a rest day for me
right tomorrow is a yes okay thank god okay because I really
need the rest right now I'm so tired Double streams made me
so tired.
So I'm like, oh, thank God.
It's a rest day.
Oh, thank God.
Because I was like, oh, man.
I don't think I have the energy for tomorrow.
I don't.
I don't think I have the fucking energy.
Um.
Yes, everybody.
It was such a fun time.
Today was actually really fun.
I was honestly so nervous.
Uh.
So nervous today in Rust.
And I like that.
I'm happy that I was able to have such a fun experience.
In Rust with everybody.
And just like talking to.
Making like new friends and stuff.
And role playing.
Because I'm always scared of role playing.
Because I'm very scared of like.
I feel like I'm not a very good role player.
So like I'm always super scared about role playing.
just because i don't think i'm good at role playing so i'm
glad that like i'm glad that i was able to to art like you
know make it entertaining for people and had like really
good role players to like uh um to like uh bounce off on um
i it was crazy okay so i actually knew about the whole the
blood god shit like because i remember i used to watch like
uh i remember i watched the very first rest arc so the very
very first rest arc with like the when the blood god thing
first started uh very like like i think like two years ago
um two years ago like the very first time the blood god
thing started two years ago and i used to watch that i
remember watching that too on stream it's a consistent lore
yeah it's not like this is new so um so like i was so yeah
it was during the pandemic so when the fact that i was able
to like be a part of it because this was like pre like you
know before i was like a streamer thing before i was like a
Remember watching shit like that, like, watching it,
watching...
It wasn't even two years.
Was it three years ago?
Holy shit, that was so long ago.
Like, I think it was like three plus years ago when the
Blood God thing first started.
And the fact that, like, I got to be part of it now, it was
four years ago?
Oh my god!
My god!
Anyway, like I said, that I got a chance to actually be part
of the Blood God call.
cult something I watched four years ago when I was like a
nobody and then like four years later like I actually got to
meet Will Will Neff and like actually got a like RP and
joined the cult and everything oh my god like that shit was
that shit blew my mind like I was you know like role playing
as like super gullible and oblivious and stuff like that
because I didn't you know because like for you know for the
rp sick um and uh and it was just it was crazy i thought it
was like crazy uh to be able to rp stuff like that uh for
people that like i used to watch for four plus years ago and
like also interact with like you were acting okay maybe it's
like half acting
half acting um yeah so it was pretty fun i had a great time
playing uh rest and i'm really happy that gumi gave her time
to uh take give me give me a tour you know give me a tour
and like introduce me to some people and like uh like you
know start the roleplay stuff and everything so yeah i had a
great time um and a great time playing with tension today
And just like hang out with Tengen and uh, you know, like
we've actually we've actually uh hanged out a lot off stream
with like gaming and stuff like Apex and stuff like that and
just chatting.
So like it was great to be able to hang out with him on
stream and being able to just you know, uh, like just like
fuck around and stuff on stream and having guys watch too.
So, it was great.
Had a great time.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to call it here today.
Thank you, everybody, for the super chats and, you know, and
the subs, because I was going to say, I might read some
super chats, but I realized I haven't had dinner yet, and
it's 8 p.m.
So, I should order something before, I should order
something before, like, restaurants start closing.
So, I'm going to call it here, everybody.
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye